I think I learned how to do exams in
University I didn't learn how to do that
I barely passed bro oh you barely passed
dude I think I think by the end of my
uni like I had like I think I had just
passed the bare minimum to graduate by
like six points or something which is
like nothing yeah and I got that paper I
was like I learned the entire meal deal
menu combination I went through all of
it Tesco Express on our campus I learned
where every Pub was in the
campus yeah I mean I I think every
University student learns that
especially I'll say it I Le the most
valuable thing of all what social life
how to socialize true the most valuable
that is true that is that is true
University I mean like I I was just not
social before and I I think that I
underestimated how doing my job now and
even when I do things that aren't
entertainment and not like YouTube I'm
doing like just straight business talks
or trying to discuss things being able
to pick up on social cues and knowing
confidence in social situations is
genuinely an invaluable thing that you
need in life and I think University
really kind of gave me the kickart to
get there cuz you you you rock up and
it's like Battle Royale social simulator
like well [__] I got to startop making
some [__] friends or I'm going to be
I'm going to be [__] in this you also
turn into like the deep end of the
independency pool right where you're
just like oh well there's no like
teachers there for you to like you know
make friends for you or like there's no
parents always like hovering behind you
or anything like that that's also
important because that's the last time
in life you're going to get a shared
experience with everyone around you
that's true uh after that no one has
shared experiences it's gone it's the
one time where you kind of get to make
friends for free you have this one
joining Factor where you can you can
kind of all relate to and that's gone so
that it's you don't realize it but like
it's kind of the training wheels for
being social MH and it's really the last
chance you have because yeah some people
don't in high school but a lot of people
don't and that's that's fine because
you're you're worried about other [__]
like how how to [__] spell English
words correctly which I still didn't
figure out um so you know I think it's
it's important to make sure you learn
how to get social skills and for me
that's what university was that's what
the [__] did we learn in high school or
secondary school I don't know just how
to
exist exist existing is hard I found a
lot of like the hobbies that I still was
easy back then yeah for for me high
school was important cuz I found a lot
of the hobbies that I still hold dear to
my heart like I think it was the first
step like as you said like it's kind of
the training wheels to figure out start
to figure out okay who am I exactly you
know and then I'm a [__] D [__] D
I'm a [__] DJ baby know it's it's the
first time you really start having some
form of responsibility which is you know
grades come into the question in high
school you don't have any grades really
you got to go to school every day go to
school and then now now you're like okay
well [__] I got to worry about this
thing I have to start actually managing
my time you start learning really Core
Concepts and then I feel like after that
they like learning social skills of
being encouraged to do so is really a
side Factor all of the time because
teachers don't care either cuz I don't
[__] care I don't give a [__] about
this kid being social it's not my
responsibility I got to teach him math
and then you get to University you're
like oh [__] I have to learn this for
myself now otherwise I'm going to be
lonely yeah yeah I feel like teachers
care even less in University oh they
don't give a [__] all their
responsibility it's their it's their
side projects on the research project
they're actually doing yeah it's like
you're the adult that it's the L adult
training wheels it's like you must be an
adult but okay hold on let's give you
three years to figure it all out don't
we don't you russan in the world being
dumb all right mean other other they go
[__] straight into it I have mad
respect they were able to make that
decision and be like [__] it I want to
work University is like you're an adult
well are you really but no you're an
adult I swear I swear down and then you
go to the adult world and you realize oh
they were [__] lying to me they were
giving me adult easy mode and then the
people who don't want to do that take a
gap you and like I'm not ready yet oh
[__] dude I thought I had bills figured
out in universities I had like two bills
to pay I was like this [__] easy bro
paying bills is easy and then nowadays
I'm like oh [__] okay I'm juggling all
these things all right I got to pay all
these bills holy [__] how much is my
health insurance what yeah oh do you
know I land in University I [__] hate
housemates really yes I like housemates
you like housemates I kind of miss not
having a housemate yeah I supp I have
Sydney I don't really count Sydney AEM
yeah she is a housemate but would you
she's that is a [__]
housemate no that's different it's
different it's a housemate that you bone
sometimes and you go to dates with all
right all right that's already quite
different I think a lot of housemates
did that in my
univers sometimes you bone your house
but this is 24/7 bone and committ and no
what the bone in the loud okay the point
is that I mean you kind of get the same
things that prop up it's a bit different
right because you you know but there are
the same things pop sometimes maybe
maybe Joey you're you're the bad
housemate and you don't do your dishes
maybe Ani has to do them for you you
know what I mean housemates is where I
learned oh not everyone does have the
shame shared experience yeah was my
first rude awakening to be like I there
is this basic etiquette I thought I was
brought up in in a certain household and
this person doesn't [__] do it and
you either got to teach him and be an
[__] like the guy like the guy who
had the wine glass in the underwear
drawer
right there was a fork actually or Fork
maybe you didn't know things as well was
there anything that you didn't you were
like shocked to learn when you got to
University I feel like I'm a good house
mate I was that's what they s the only
thing I did was take up freezer space
because my that was my mother taking up
all the freezer space with uh takeaway
boxes well they probably thought the
same thing they were like this
[__] taking up the freezer space
okay there's a difference between taking
up freezer space and leaving my [__]
fork in your underwear used underwear
drawer okay Jo [__] up yeah that's
[__] up I got pissed off this one guy
used my pizza tray which admittedly
wasn't expensive it was like a pound but
he used my pizza tray to cook a whole
[__] chicken and that it was just
there was just charred bits of chicken
that I could never get off this pizza
tray and I thought what a [__] he didn't
even clean it he left it there for three
days so the chicken was fused with this
tray I got so annoyed cuz I was like man
have you no respect for other people's
property come on man I just like I I got
to a point where I just realized if I
buy milk I need to drink this as or use
this as fast as possible because it is
no matter I gave up on milk and bread
yeah yeah exactly I had to buy the tiny
milks which is a thing in the UK I love
this thing I wish Japan did this well
they kind of do but it's not the same
yeah they have like they used to have
like the two two three liter big jugs of
milk that and they had the one liter and
they had like the the 250 or 300 ml
little cotton of milk it so [__] well
Japan has like the 300 mil cotton but
that I I I okay I I hate the [__]
cboard boxes for milk I like the plastic
one the one we had in the UK I love that
those are pretty good so nice cuz you
can also pick it up and see how much you
have left I don't can you pull it up UK
milk Cottons this so good I I really
really hate the American and Japanese
are we [__] just shouting out milk
cartons
now this one look at this one look at
this one down here
yoow those on yeah yeah those ones yeah
we had those in Australia as well you
guys learned yeah we taught you right
yeah we we and look at the mini one the
mini one the mini one the mini ones yeah
those are the best the mini one this is
my favorite one time the the the the
bottom no no no yeah left of that left
of that
that's no no no no yeah you're so close
left left left left it's that one yeah
that one that one that one yeah that one
yeah look at that thing yeah that's a
mini one look at it that's that's a tiny
one that's little little baby one I love
this but bread bread there was no many
bread unfortunately no bread bread for
one person in the UK you know cuz when I
go to America I'm like why does your
bread last 3 weeks what's going on here
cuz in the UK it would last a week if
you're lucky you know day three it's
already like starting to be pretty hard
uh yeah so you know and that's that's
the stuff with the artificial uh stuff
kind of preserving it the really fresh
bread day two is danzo why are we raving
over mil cons bro cuz what a fantastic
design really I think we should really
you know encourage designs like this to
be more common place yeah plastic but
I've already given up bro on on micro
Plastics I'm done bro it's already over
for us at least let me enjoy my [__]
milk cars me stopping it isn't going to
save the [__] Turtles at this point
in Japan they they recycle the milk
cotton or the the the Plastics okay yeah
to be fair like Japan is kind of like
hypocritical in that sense cuz they're
like oh all of the milks are in paper so
that we can recycle them but we're also
going to individually wrap every single
piece of gum in a packet as well with
[__] and then what happens to all
this plastic in Japan uh in most places
burnt y so fantastic yes it's burn made
for electricity but it's still burning
it so I'm like let me have my [__]
milk cotton stop stop wrapping the
bananas I will I will I will I will take
not wrapping Banas for milk Cottons like
this you want to get rid of the wrapping
of the bananas I don't need a plastic
enclosure for the B Oh I thought you
meant like the skin no oh no what the
heck unskinned bananas they plastic bag
bananas here I don't want that uned
bananas they selling unpeeled bananas
now what I think I was a good housemate
though other than my incessant shouting
um but that's a pretty big bad one so
it's fair yeah that's that that would
piss me off if I was waking up for if I
was hung over and I just heard oh
I want to kill ask my old house M I'll
be I'm going to ask right now hopefully
hopefully she replies I'll be like what
was I what was the the strong points in
bad point was I was my hello yeah I only
had housemates uh for like what three
months maybe when I first moved to Japan
but that's because when I first moved to
Japan I didn't have like my own place
and it was a lot harder to like get your
own place before moving to the country
right so I moved in with a friend of
mine two friends of mine uh which I'm
sure if you know history of my channel
you know who they are but um yeah uh I
didn't like it I I I realized I was like
3 months was more than enough to be like
oh I don't like housemates even if you
have friends you don't necessarily get
along well with them when you're living
together constantly also it beats that
no other feeling than going downstairs
at like 9:00 p.m. they're chilling
you're like what are you watching like
Lord of the Rings I'm halfway through it
I'm like oh I'm in oh yeah I had moments
like that to [__] yeah I moment say that
too but I was also just kind of like oh
you know what I kind of like my own
privacy sometimes and like just having
your own room is that's that's the big
difference because I'm I was never that
guy who just saw people watching a film
and was just like oh yeah I'll join
because to me I was always in the mood
of I'm not really in the mood to watch
this right now maybe I'll watch it some
other time I had arrogates to play like
I I would rather do that you don't want
to be social that's what I'm hearing I
do want to be social social on your
parameters I want to be social Yes
actually yes it's called being an
introvert I want to be social when I'm
ready to be social going to say no to
Lord of the Rings especially if my boy's
watching it I'm like all right okay come
on let's get watched I just like you
tell me if I wasn't like if if you walk
downstairs and TR off I'm watching Lord
of the Rings I'm halfway through it wait
which one of you hasn't watched Lord of
the Rings it was [__] you I knew it
was you well we we did watch Lord of the
Rings we have now watched we did this in
Hawaii one we someone put Lord of the
Rings on one of the hotel rooms and we
all just stopped and started watching we
watch Return of the King yeah I'm going
be real if if I had my own room I
probably would have [__] off yeah it
was in God's room we all went to G room
for some reason and then I was because
we were going to have drinks and then
you put on rings and I'm like well guys
by the way this is the third movie and I
haven't watched either one of the re
like the previous ones and you guys were
like don't care bro we're going to go
out that's right we all met in dance
room and I put on TV and I was fcking
through chance I saw a Lord of the Rings
and then we all were like five of us we
were like let's hang out let's just
watch lot of the r i mean like bang a
movie I was like guys I haven't seen
that and you like well the G there's
never a bad time to watch Lord of the
Rings I think I think even watching them
out of order is okay because they just
start bang a movies in order out they is
that a take who cares like John Wick
right exactly like John Wick actually of
the Ring stands the test of time G point
being I'm sure it does I'm sure it does
I was a great housemate generally I was
a fantastic I just don't believe people
who say that you know dude I I I cleaned
the most which I feel is the the hardest
part of being a housemate oh I I cleaned
the most as well um um did you clean
of course I did yeah did you have a
cleaning r no no I was the [__] maid
of the house bro I don't believe it I
don't we're we're in a [__] True
Crime investigation now I heard that
stutter in the voice
yeah I got clean Psy
anals pauses right now what we have here
is a man who just got caught in a lie
noticed that his eyes looked up to the
left inciting that he might have
potentially lied when you play La no all
want the detective will now realize this
lie and continue the line of
Investigation in this direction so Joey
we know you didn't clean you can like we
have the evidence right you can we know
you didn't clean we saw the crime scene
we we have the we have the roommate's
testimony right here oh really in the
other room they ratted you out it'll be
easy on you just to uh admit now we have
an anonymous tip for someone Joey we can
help you out if you just confess if you
just tell us you didn't claim that much
we can do we can help you out no I did
actually clean though how do you okay
what do you look for what would you look
for in a good roommate then aside from
obviously companionship because
hopefully you're living with people that
you like which is the bare minimum of
what you would hope for in a good
roommate um I mean honestly if your if
your roommate's kind of in the same
friend group as you it's chill because
you can all just hang out and then when
you go out they can join you it's just
Good Vibes it's just one okay one one
one other thing as well which is an
unfortunate reality I've never been in a
flat where you know if it was like more
than five people there would always be
some kind of drama around some bills
getting paid and I think that was that
and I think that is the [__] massive
thing where that is like the Friendship
Ender of like how okay you can get along
perfectly well with someone you you can
[__] chill with them but as soon as
this kind of like fincial responsib
responsibility comes into play that is
what I found to be friendship Enders not
for just people that I had red with in
the past but from what I've heard from
people around me as well um cuz
unfortunately some people are just
really [__] irresponsible and I think
being roommates with someone is a big
tell about you can are you cool with
someone you can be totally cool with
someone but they can also just be a
completely like irresponsible person in
some things that now is affecting your
life I think that's the I think he just
described why content creator houses
just don't work out in the long run
either right because like I feel the
same phenomenon happens where it's like
oh I really like this other person I
like making content with them I I
respect them as a Creator blah blah blah
but it's very different living with that
person where you see everything else
right and they might not be as like
mature or right in the head as they make
themselves out to be on camera and of os
in a room and get a bunch of os in a
room and then yeah it all [__]
crumbles apart you know yeah yeah uh I
mean I think it was my University and I
think even more so my London experience
cuz London fled London Shar flats and
houses uh was such an awful [__]
experience for me that I was like I
think I'm good you had a horrible
experience which I think easily could
Define how you view it I think that's
fair it only takes one man yeah I think
it takes just one bad neighbor or one
bad roommate to be like I'm I'm [__]
done [__] this I'm I'm I'm [__] I'm
[__] done I'm I'm only living with my
life partner and uh that's that's pretty
much it for roommates yeah um though you
figured it out man you crack I do like
to have fun with the boys just not
always living with them constantly but
you know maybe some people do actually
like roommates it is kind of scary well
like every time we go to America like
how many like especially creators ask
like oh so do you guys like live in a
house yeah like in a in a Creator house
what scares me more isn't how many
creators live in the house it's how big
some of the content houses are fail I a
lot of them are destined to fail almost
cuz you just can't have that many egos
in in one building I mean even with some
creatures that I'm totally chill with
it's not even about egos but when you
have [__] nine people in the house
I'm like this is that's a party this is
too much this is too many people that I
am constantly around even if I'm totally
chill with everyone here um and that's
too much to manage for me yeah but hey
in [__] in a in a city like la in a
city in a major city like New York
sometimes you just have to room with
someone yeah uh and I think I learned
early on that I guess it's just worth
moving out uh to find someone more
affordable if only you could afford it
though and that's why people are doomed
in this day and age it really has been a
Duma podcast hasn't it it's been a Duma
podcast as equally what a way what a way
to end the year all we've talked about
this podcast to end the year of 2023 off
is talk about fetishes uh doom and over
stimulation